hello folks
welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics
everybody else does what they do math
and irrational explanations
and hopefully physics is a branch of
science and science hopefully is
always rational uh
today's show again uh we divided in
three parts
first part we're going to do a little
bit of extinction theory
uh quite popular subject in fact
and then we're going to go into the
specific lecture today which is
d coherence quantum decoherence
what the hell is that we'll find out
today
and then at the end i'm gonna entertain
questions and comments that people made
since last time since sunday
okay so let's get started with uh
extinction
here's the first question comment person
says fake money
fueled hyper liberalism
is the uh is the plague
okay so fake money fueled by i guess by
hyper
liberalism is the plague that's that's
the problem okay
has led to environmental destruction
individualism breakdown of the family
and all variety of other ills
crypto ransom attacks are being done by
intelligence agencies okay
cyber pandemic uh to follow the world
nonsense
the covet nonsense and allows them to
bring heavy controls down the line
they're gonna be controlling us you know
the
elites uh and another fellow answers uh
first guy says the elite cabal do all
these
psyops okay they use
uh fear to make s sheep believe
their narrative to control where they
want to steer us
they don't want us to own any crypto
lots of people do politics and they have
strong opinions and all i can say is you
know uh first uh
here in this channel we try to do
science and not
religion politics is a branch of
religion
politics is about opinions and
recommendations how the world should be
run
and boy we have eight billion opinions
on you
on planet earth everybody has an opinion
and a recommendation of how everything
should be done
we're all experts on our opinions
incredible
what what a coincidence and no i'm
saying uh
you know you should stray away from
um opinions from politics i'm saying you
know you have to
uh try to do um extinction in other
words you try to do
explanations okay and here's uh my
answer is there a global cabal
okay first of all i mean are we saying
that uh
here you have the communists like the
north koreans you have the iranians
the americans which are their enemies
the russians the chinese
all these people got together and they
decided to
form a global cabal you know
elite you know i have doubts about that
and uh you know i i i think that's
unlikely even for this covid thing
it's it's very unlikely that all these
uh heads of state
that hate each other you know they got
together and they decided to
carry this conspiracy against uh their
own people
out there okay and um yeah
i mean you do have a situation where um
let me put this over here
you do have a situation where um
you know there are in different
countries a lot of the hospitals
with respect to this covet issue
what they're doing is you know they get
funds from the government if
they deal with this covet issue which is
an emergency situation
and so what happens is i'm sure that
because of how we are as humans
a lot of these hospitals are you know if
you have cancer they'll put you under
covid because they get funds they don't
get any funds if they put under
cancer so some of that might be
happening out there uh
in my mind i think that's very possible
but that's a different uh
issue things of that nature are
different
than saying that the government the
heads of governments have put their
heads together
and form this unique cabal that somehow
works in conjunction with each other or
together you know uh i don't know i
i have i have a problem with that i
don't think it's happening
and then um and
then you have uh this uh you know stay
away from politics
and you should emphasize understanding
and
versus opinion and emphasize explanation
versus you know recommending uh
this opinion and recommendation
no that's religion that's that's uh
subjective
uh understanding and explaining that's
got to do more with science that's what
we do here so you know
try to stick to explaining and
understanding
okay mechanism especially in regards to
physics and extinction i think is a
branch of physics
in other words uh paleontology if you
want that that part of
paleontology extinction that's got to do
with physics you know uh
us dying how did the animals in the past
die
all that's part of physics so you know
we focus on understanding and explaining
okay next issue uh
here it goes follow says
i believe that the heat absorption
ability of co2
is non-linear when this is ignored in
addition to other modifiers the models
become
quite exaggerated and scary it must be
on purpose
he's referring again to politics and
he's referring to
climate change which is a popular
subject out there today
okay and yeah what can i say um
unfortunately you know i think it's very
misleading
uh that so many people are involved
into client or in this subject of
climate change
i think it's a totally irrelevant at
least with respect to extinction
has no bearing whatsoever not a single
species in the history of life on earth
ever died because of climate change
okay uh and that's again i've
talked about that in the past but in in
general
a lot of people think that maybe the
animals in the past
that that died in mass extinction
especially uh
died because or disappeared they became
extinct because
there was a climate change that somehow
affected the plants
the plants disappeared and then the
herbivores disappeared and then the
carnivores disappeared that's
that's their reasoning and they don't go
beyond that
but there's a lot of problems with that
and the biggest problem is
why did other animals continue why did
the mammals continue and the dinosaurs
died
specifically when it was a chronological
extinction
the animals that died not only were the
big ones and the masters
the rulers of the planet but they were
the old
species and it turns out that's the same
thing that happened
at the end of the jurassic triassic
permian
carboniferous or division all of them
you know
what you have is the old species die and
the new ones continue
no asteroid no climate change no disease
can do that
and again you know you have the issue on
land and
in the seas very strange that animals on
both sides the old ones the big ones the
rulers of the planets both on land
and sea and in the air those were the
ones that went away
in the mass extinctions the ones that
remained were the young ones the little
guys
that radiated with the new vegetation
that was also into working for millions
of years
okay so yeah climate change has in my
humble opinion i do not subscribe to
that theory i think it has nothing to do
with extinction
okay another fellow says you call
economy which is what you are talking
about when you talk about
money ending and humans becoming extinct
the management of resources
this meaning doesn't have scientific
rationale
i guess you meant rationale with an e as
it's not
uh consistent or rigorous either one
uh yeah he's right uh
you know what what do we mean by
management of resources
how scientific is that so he's got a
point there
but uh my answer to this is that the
word
economics or economy
uh it's not an important word
in the theory of extinction at all okay
and so let me put in the proper context
okay
economy and economics and other
derivative words
related to those they're general terms
used for closing
arguments okay so when we say economic
collapse
we're referring to a little something a
little different
the key issue is that money you know
uh is is what disappears the end of
money people stop
believing in money what is money well
it's an object or concept that is traded
that is exchanged uh the key issue also
is trade you know
exchange and the other key issue is
end of faith faith and what well maybe
faith in god you know
in god we stop trusting okay we lose
faith in god
faith in god and no one wants him
anymore
okay so that's what that's all about and
uh so
the word the key word is not economy the
key word is
trade or money you know those are the
ones we're going to use to make our
case okay now as a closing argument we
synthesize and say uh uh you know the
economy collapsed
okay or something along those lines you
know it's
it's just uh like a synthesis a summary
that's all it is
uh nothing more what is economic
collapse it just means that
trade is no more money is no more okay
and so this takes us to the word trade
what people have in mind usually is that
trade has to do with you know a seller
and a buyer
okay and i have a problem with that
serious problem with that uh seller and
buyer
that's known as communism okay
you have a seller buyer situation you
have communism
and uh that's not very
equitable okay it's not not not very
nice to have a a seller and a buyer
okay that's known as communist let me go
to them i mean you have this situation
you have
seller buyer you can have a buyer buyer
and you can have a seller seller
so let me go through those so that you
understand the difference
okay so we have this situation you have
a seller buyer situation that's
known as communism okay you have a giver
and a taker
okay uh put freddie the free loader for
those who
know who he was uh red skelton he he did
this uh
freddie freeloader and you have a you
know
someone who gives and another one who
receives
and you say well the receiver gives
something in exchange
uh no because if he gives something in
exchange
he's a seller he's not a receiver he's
not a buyer he's a seller
okay so seller buyer is communism
someone gives the other guy receives
okay and that situation is not very
equitable
okay and you can take it from uh
communist president of the united states
mr abraham lincoln who said
all men are created equal
and his secretary of war edwin stanton
said
you're mistaken mr president and that's
why he had him murdered
okay so uh no seller buyer
that's communism okay what's uh buyer
buyer here's buyer buyer
okay and this is this ideal society that
some people
out there have that we're gonna evolve
into a worthless society
where i guess the robots do all the work
and
we just you know sit back and have
24-hour leisure
and just receive you know it's the world
of heaven
all the angels out there they're all
equal you know and so uh
they don't have any responsibilities i i
don't think playing the harp is a
responsibility it's just
leisure and they just receive they
somehow
live you know
manna you know comes from heaven it's
free
we all receive we're all buyers
you know we're all recipients
and that's an idealistic society uh
that some people have in mind they think
that's gonna eventually evolve
is that how we're gonna live for the
next million years or billion years uh
here on earth eternity essentially and
we're just going to be receiving
manna from heaven the robots do all the
work we don't do anything
uh great society again no i think that's
after you die then you go to heaven
hopefully you go to heaven right and
um and then you become a soul lost in
in the clouds then maybe you'll get that
world but i don't think you'll get it
here on earth
okay so what's uh the other one well the
other one's known as capitalism and
that's seller seller
okay you have a seller seller situation
everybody sells something
i sell you money and you sell me the
yacht
okay and that's known as capitalism
and that's how the system really works
you know everybody has capitalism
here on earth even in cuba north korea
and china they call themselves
communist countries they i don't think
so you know
they have a seller seller society
primarily where uh everybody hustles
does something and trades whatever they
made or
uh in the case of services whatever
service they provide
for something else okay so the seller
seller society
is what i'm saying is going to die
okay because once no one wants the
currency
used for all these transactions which
are
you know money in different forms again
it's just an object that we trade could
be a concept that we trade
an illusion that we have that something
has value that we want
it could be money it could be a number
in a computer
you know it could be cryptocurrency
would it cryptocurrency just a number
in fact it's a code it's not even a
number
and we're going to be like that what for
the next billion years
what what other type of currency can you
imagine and the
abstractions that we have today
so again to think that you know uh we're
going to be trading for the rest of
eternity
when our economy right now is a great
global economy as i see it is grinding
to a stop
well i don't know uh i don't think it's
uh ever going to happen
that we're going to live forever that
that we're going to be exchanging goods
forever
no at some point money is going to die
we're going to lose faith in money
and the reason we're going to lose faith
and money is that um
the value of money that whatever we use
for transactions the currency is going
to
go so low that and more and more people
will be at the lower
end of the receiving end of that money
that it's not even going to be
worthwhile to work
because you can barely make it with that
to the end of the month
and more and more people will be at that
level
at some point you know people start
going out breaking windows you know
complaining in different countries of
the world and at some point the system
is going to break down
the the elites the
elite cabals as the fellow said uh
won't be able to handle the situation
anymore what are they gonna do print
more money
what fiscal monetary policy are they
gonna introduce
when when it's so limited today already
and what are they gonna just put more
money in circulation devalue the coin
even further
so at some point things are gonna break
down because you cannot create
more and more wealth okay especially
um smaller percentages
you know it's a it's going to be a
decreasing uh
creation of wealth and spread among ever
more people
that's what you're going to have a
situation like that where at some point
people are just gonna start complaining
because they can't
make it to the end of the month they
can't pay their rent they can't buy all
the food with the money you give them or
just barely there and
more and more people will be at that
level so at some point the global system
will collapse
and i think it's coming down the you
know down the hall it's
very close by uh when is it going to
happen people always ask well that's
religion you know uh
that's astrology i don't have a crystal
ball to tell you
what day it's going to happen is going
to happen the year 2023 on the 1st of
may now
i can't tell you that all i can tell you
we can't be going too far i doubt very
much we're going to go past
mid-century i'm not even sure we're
going to make it to mid-century
so this is it folks uh be prepared we
may be
the last humans on earth last generation
of humans on earth
so look around you those people we're
all part of that
generation that you know shuts the light
on earth okay
so here's a summary of those three
possibilities we have the seller buyer
that's communism
we have the buyer buyer that's an
unemployment society you can
call it a leisure society maybe okay
everybody just receives and
i guess the robots do all the work
whatever works out there i don't know if
they'll be doing
services uh what are we going to be
doing just exchanging
bitcoins through the internet what kind
of services are we going to be doing oh
none because it's an unemployment
society that's true so nobody does any
work right
great society if you can imagine it
maybe in heaven
and then you have the seller seller
society which is the one that's worked
so far
in civilization since we started
civilization
since we started commercial farming okay
and uh
that's exchange of goods and services
and that's worked
pretty nicely so far but now we're
getting to the point we're doing
a lot more service a lot of abstraction
and leaving the the real material things
like food and tangible things behind
okay so that's a summary for uh what
trade is
okay i always recommend
try to recommend lately that people do
extinction 101 before they do
102. 101 is past extinctions
okay animals
we're part of the animal kingdom but
some people think we're different
we usually say oh he's an animal that's
an animal okay over there but we're
animals too
but you know you know what i'm saying
i'm saying that we had past extinctions
mass extinctions and certain types of
animals orders of
in complete orders of animals
disappeared massively
in a short period of time geological
time and we want to understand that
process what happened to them
and you can't use asteroids you can't
use catastrophic
agents such as volcanoes and
what is it the supernovas things of that
nature
because you would not be able to explain
the only thing an extinction a
mass extinction theory has to explain
which is
selectivity you have to explain how
mother nature selects
one order and allows another one to
continue
especially when the order to disappear
you know this is a chronological
extinction
means that the old ones and the big ones
are the ones that disappear
and the young ones the the new
generation of animals
uh that came from behind that was in you
know hiding uh
in smallness they were the small little
guys
you know at the feet of the big guys and
those were that
the ones that came up after the big guys
were gone that's what happened
so it's the big guys and the
old guys that disappeared and the ones
that continued into mass extinction
always in every single case no exception
we're the young guys
and young guys and small guys typically
okay
um and then you can move on to
extinction 102 which is human extinction
okay so human extinction is what well uh
us
if we can uh figure out how the animals
in the past died we can project that to
our species
and figure it over to our not only our
species but all the animals out there
today
okay especially the mammals because i
think it's going to be
a mass extinction of the mammals
primarily
and we can project it onto the mammals
and say well is there a way that we can
avoid the same mechanism that
triggered the extinction of animals in
the past that's the logic behind
uh using doing 101 before 102.
and again i'll put the homework up there
which is a single question that will
help you resolve this
and the homework is why did the fauna in
the
seas disappear at the same time more or
less at the same time as the animals on
land
okay they're two different environments
why would they disappear more or less at
the same time maybe within a few
thousand years but geologically
speaking about the same time why did
they disappear at the same
time if you can answer that question
maybe you have zeroed in
on the mechanism of it of a mass
extinction
okay okay um
so uh let's continue now with
um uh the lecture of today
lecture today what is it it's uh d
coherence quantum
d coherence what the hell is that
one of the coherence but before we can
do go in there
it's good to introduce the subject
with a little article that came out
today
it doesn't have to do with quantum but
it's got to do with the way the
mathematicians
think and the type of problems they're
finding
and the ones that they cannot answer
okay so here it goes this is this is the
issue
the article says a strange galaxy
galaxy 72 million light years away seems
to be missing
its dark matter
and if you read the article it says if
the galaxy were closer to earth
then than initially proposed it would
intrinsically
be less massive meaning it would have to
have
more dark matter to look the way it does
turns out that the new measurements
however showed
uh that this galaxy is actually farther
away
than scientists initially thought at 70
72 million light years instead of 65
million
okay so that means uh it's got
no dark matter at all then or very
little
and so the question is uh do we have a
problem here where
we have all these mathematicians and
they do all these cal
they do measurements they do
calculations and they reach these
conclusions
talking uh you know explaining the
phenomena with
dark matter and they don't have any idea
what dark matter is they tell you in
your face oh we don't know by the way
what dark matter is
some exotic type of matter that we can't
see
why because they're talking about mass
that's what they're talking about
they're talking about a concept known as
mass
mathematical concept known as mass and
they're going to do all their
calculation with mass because that's
what they do all day they just do
calculations they just put these
numbers in an equation and from there
they want to extrapolate
a physical interpretation and that's
when they invent these concepts
not objects invent these concepts known
as
dark matter or black hole or space
space-time
they have all these concepts which they
turn into objects because they're going
to
give you a physical interpretation
for their conclusion how they
perceive the universe okay and that's
more or less like
you know in the old days traditional
religions they would introduce god
because they didn't know any better
and they said well uh the god of the
wind maybe
or you know maybe god you know he
intervened singing his angels
because they could not explain certain
things so they had to introduce these
uh fantastic uh things out there they
created these monsters these
these spirits they call god or angels or
whatever they
they invented out there because they had
no way of explaining
and this is absolutely no different in
fact that's even worse because
god you can always imagine god you know
he looks like us more or less you know
he's got eyes ears mild hands
belly button he's got the whole works
maybe not belly button i don't know
because
he would need a mother for that but um
you know we can imagine that we cannot
imagine what these people are saying
what is dark matter what is space time
what is a black hole no such monsters
you know black holes are dimensional
dark matter is invisible
space-time is a concept and so
a mathematical concept so you can't use
those as physical
objects and say i'm going to give you a
physical interpretation you know gravity
is the warping of space
what sense does that make if
space-time's not a physical object you
can't talk about
warping a concept and so this is where
the problem is
and that's why they cannot explain you
know
give you a physical interpretation for
dark matter for how this
galaxy you know doesn't behave the way
they thought it should be
behaving i mean if dark matter is
everywhere in every galaxy in the
universe it should be in this one in
fact
they found three other galaxies that
have the same problem
that they cannot explain exactly
you know uh why they don't they seem to
lack
dark matter you say okay what's this got
to do with the subject matter of today
well
the coherence is more or less on the
same uh page
okay what they're going to be doing is
they're going to give you
this decoherence explanation which is no
explanation at all
they're just going to say oh by the way
we don't understand it we we have no
idea how that works
in the sub-atomic world but
thanks to the coherence and you know
superposition
and entanglement and all these other
quantum phenomena
we have computers and we have what was
it the other day we talked about
quantum dots we have all this technology
so they're trying to give you a physical
interpretation especially i want you to
keep this in mind today
they're going to try to give you what is
known as a classical
explanation something which is tangible
and sealable
okay parting from a point where they
talk about quantum
processes which they cannot see or touch
so they're gonna extrapolate from
quantum mechanics
untouchable unseeable unobservable okay
to the classical world which is the
touchable seeable world
okay so they're going to give you a
physical interpretation of a seeable
touchable world
parting from the base of unseeable
unobservable
of quantum okay so that's that's and
that's the same thing that happens with
this dark matter thing
okay so let's get on with it here's a
quantum income what i call
uh quantum incoherence
okay what is this a quantum uh
d coherence well first we gotta
understand what uh coherence mean
quantum coherence okay
and here's a brief uh statement okay
definition you can say quantum coherence
is the ability of a quantum system to
demonstrate
interference interference what are you
talking about
american football uh you
play interference or something like that
running back and you have all this
interference in front of you what is
this
and then we'll get into that in a second
and uh what is the coherence
well the coherence can be viewed as the
loss of
information okay that's how they explain
it from a system
into the environment there's kind of
interference from the environment atoms
light whatever
uh maybe even the background radiation
whatever that is okay all this
is interfering with some of the
experiments that
that these folks do in the lab and they
say
okay there's some interference there and
as long as we can show interference
okay what does it say there to
demonstrate interference if you can
demonstrate that and you have coherence
it's only when you cannot demonstrate it
because you cannot see
all these environmental atoms and things
that are out all these spirits and
ghosts that are out there
okay but they don't like to call them
spirits and ghosts because
you're gonna say well what are you doing
what are you doing you're doing
traditional religion again
and they call them you know they say
well there's atoms out there that we
can't see there's
light there's radiation there's
background stuff you know that we can't
see
and that's interfering did you see it
that you observe it did you touch it
we inferred it from the things that we
can see
and touch which are what classical
mechanics
okay so that's that's how this thing is
going to evolve okay so keep all this in
mind because that's what
quantum
decoherence is all about okay
okay so um what is what is this
interference that they're talking about
well fortunately we have uh mr feynman
he was
richard feynman he was a nobel prize
1965
said to be a good teacher okay and he
explained a lot of stuff
in quantum mechanics explained with
quotations
he always said well we cannot explain
it's all descriptions which is correct
they don't explain they they describe
mathematically
they infer irrational explanations from
that
and they call the whole shebang
especially the description part they
call them theories
and no theory is an explanation and and
in science we only accept
rational explanations and none of
none of the ones coming out of quantum
or general relativity and strengthening
are rational that's that's where our
criticism is
in this channel okay so what are we
talking about interference well we're
talking about the slit experiment that's
where it starts
okay a slit experiment you send a light
through two slits monochromatic light
goes through two slits
and instead of seeing two lines on the
screen behind it you see fringes
many fringes and how's that possible
if light consists of little particles
well you should see only two
lines but they say well light behaves
kind of weird because it turns into this
wavy thingy and the wave
interferes with itself on the other side
of the two slits
that's essentially in a nutshell what
this slit experiment
is and mr feinman tells us you know
in very precise language you know
uh he tells us how to explain the slit
experiment
okay and here it is he says the
following he says we choose to examine a
phenomenon
the double slit experiment right which
is impossible
absolutely impossible to explain in any
classical way
touchable seeable observable okay
and which has in it the heart of quantum
mechanics
in reality it contains the only mystery
nobody can give you a deeper explanation
of this phenomenon
than i have given that is a description
of it okay that came out of his finding
lectures in the sixth
i think 61-63 thereabouts
um what is he saying he's saying well we
we notice this phenomenon
which we call the slit experiment was
done
uh by um
thomas young in fact he got that from
even from newton before that
to some degree you know they were aware
of this
diffraction okay it was not so precise
until it got to thomas young who
resuscitated
it and tried to explain in terms of
waves it became important because
of the wave nature of light that thomas
young
favored because he was overruling
150 or so years later he was over ruling
newton
and that was like you know we're ruling
einstein today how can you
do that here's this guru einstein you're
going to overrule him
and here we had mr thomas young and he
was saying
that the guru newton was wrong
and so yeah he received a lot of slack
for that
you know the british turned her backs on
on
good ol uh thomas young but then the
french took up on what
thomas young said have several people
rago and
forgot his name now french guy but a lot
of the french guys you know they started
picking up on
on what uh frannel that's the name i was
thinking augustine
and they started picking up on where
thomas young left off or
in parallel and they went on ahead with
a wave nature of light which was
championed by
huygens who was a contemporary of newton
so
newton was being pushed aside and he was
pushed aside through most of the 19th
century
until we again in the 20th century
resuscitated newton
and the corpuscle but the corpuscle
turned into an abstract concept
but anyways here it is you can see it
there uh
what do you have you have a machine gun
and it's shooting bullets okay particles
balls and the particle it doesn't split
into
that's not what they're saying they're
saying that the same particle is at two
places at once
it's it it's at both slits
at the same time so the particle one
particle
goes through two slits and it's the same
particle
the particle is at two places at once
then it recombines with itself okay
and on the other side on the uh screen
there it recombines and you have all
these patterns
okay these uh fringes that's essentially
what these folks are saying
okay uh yeah maybe
and what's the status of the slit
experiment today well
here you have it okay uh
it says uh this comes out of uh the
wikipedia i think it says despite nearly
a century
uh of debate okay
put this over here a little bit okay
century of debate and experiment
no consensus had been reached among
physicists and philosophers of physics
concerning which interpretation of
quantum mechanics
best represents reality and again the
the big problem as uh finance said here
is this slid experiment they cannot
explain it they cannot explain how a
particle can be at two places at once
okay and as you can see the big problem
or
is is that they're doing or they're
simulating all this
with particles with discrete particles
if we get rid of the particle then
maybe we can make some progress but as
long as we stick to the
particle hypothesis then we won't make
any sense of it
okay under the rope model here you see
the rope model
this is you know quantum mechani i mean
the slit experiment
is a piece of cake it's no no big deal
okay
all you have to do is make a new
assumption and that's that all atoms in
the
universe are interconnected physically
interconnected
what are they connected by well we say
it's an electromagnetic rope
that's what we call it in other words
we're saying that there is a
an invisible intangible entity
unobservable as they say
they say the same thing okay we're
saying the same thing here it's
invisible intangible unobservable
and that
what interconnects every atom in the
universe any two atoms are
interconnected by this rope
so what happens there you have the slit
experiment uh both
what i call the hair experiment the slit
experiment i'll go over that in a second
here
and what you have is that the ropes are
already tied
to your flashlight or you know the
monochromatic source
and what happens is it's already tied
before you turn the light on
all atoms are already interconnected
physically interconnected
when you turn the light on all you're
doing is increasing the frequency
in other words you're you're torquing
the rope at a faster rate and now you
have higher frequency
and shorter links
links of the rope and that stimulus is
uh
relayed from the hair in one case the
slits in the other
doesn't matter really and from there it
goes to the screen
to every atom of the screen because
again every atom in the screen is
bound to every atom of the needle or the
slit partition double slit partition
there which is attached to
every atom of your source okay so all
you're doing is
stimulating existing um
ropes okay
and here we have uh another
version of this so that you can see what
we're talking about a little more in
detail
okay before you turn the light on what
you have is longer
links and fewer links
which is frequency in other words you
have low frequency
uh long wavelength that's essentially
what it is
and i put the atoms there the two atoms
as black
to show that there is no light okay so
before you turn on the light you don't
see
any the atoms are not being stimulated
to
a higher frequency to a higher pumping
rate once you turn on the light you get
this bright band
and a dark band which are the middle and
the bottom one
uh cases what is a bright band well you
have higher frequency
okay and the atom is pumping
maybe wider there's there's a couple
possibilities there
there's pumping at a
back and forth the balloon is expanding
and contracting
at a higher rate or to a greater extent
okay
and what it does is uh the links are
shorter
now between any two atoms because it
relays that signal to the next atom the
atom in your eye for example or the atom
on the screen
and so that's a bright band and the dark
band is simply a slower
or shorter uh
frequent frequency in other words you
have lower frequency
and you have a longer wavelength than
the bright band
and in between you have a
nuanced a
gradient okay and here it is again
it gives you an idea what i'm referring
to here
okay we're talking about a rope
okay we're not talking about waves
okay we're talking about a rope a
physical rope so
here it is what we're saying is here you
have a rope you either have
higher frequency meaning shorter links
or you have
longer links and fewer links meaning
your frequency is lower okay that's
that's all we're saying
very simple very straightforward just
get a rope and do your own
twisting you'll see what i'm talking
about but what happens when you have
uh when they're in phase okay when the
two links
meet at an atom uh in the same phase
well then you have a bright band because
they enhance each other you have
constructive
interference and you have destructive
interference where they're exactly
opposite
and in between you have all these you
can see down at the bottom you see
these this nuance this gradient of
colors
or or of um you know
darkness and brightness why because the
rope you know you have rope doesn't if
you have the ropes like
here are two ends if they're uh let me
see if i can get this out of here
put it over here easier to show there
so if the blue or if the two blues are
on top
okay then uh you can say well uh
then they're the the um they're in phase
okay
if there one is red and the other one is
blue then you have
out of phase but then you have the
situations in between
and those are the uh the gradient that
you have
in colors and in uh shadowy you know
because it's not
a clear cut what you have is a gradient
from one bright band to the next
okay and the rope explains that quite
quite easily
in fact the explanation is not mine the
explanation really comes from the wave
nature of light
which they've already figured out they
know that if the two waves
are in um in phase
then it's a bright band if they're out
of phase it's it's a dark band and then
you have all these
in between but there is no physical
object called wave
that's the problem the problem is wave
is a bunch of vectors it's got to do
with math
a rope on the other hand this has to do
with physics now we're talking about a
real object
it's a real object and one that is
invisible and
intangible which is what quantum says
anyway so
those people who accuse me say well bill
how can an object be invisible and
intangible well that's what quantum says
as well
i haven't invented anything new there
they've been saying the same thing for
100 years
except nobody's been listening okay
according to quantum mechanics they had
to turn the so-called
photon and the so-called electron into
abstract concepts
point particles because if they use a
real particle a corpuscle
they can't do it and they know they
cannot explain it with real corpuscles
that's why they've abandoned the
newtonian
corpuscle the classical corpuscle
what we have is the quantum corpuscle
meaning
we're talking about an equation we're
talking about an abstraction they don't
care about the physical object they're
just going to be doing it with an
abstract mathematical concept we're
saying no there is a physical
object you can say it's classical if
that's the word you want to use fine no
problem
but we're talking about a real physical
object that interconnects
any two atoms okay so uh yeah we're not
talking about abstractions like in the
case of quantum mechanics
okay
here we see another version of how
they're
trying to explain the coherence one is
the slit experiment
another one is they're going to try to
stimulate an atom
and find out if it gets excited or not
and here you have two situations they
say uh
in quantum physics and atom can be
exciting
and not excited at the same time
how can that possibly be i mean here in
the first case we had
an atom a a an electron or
a photon can be at two places at once
the ball can be at two places at once
and since they can't do it with a ball
they turn that into a concept they say
the abstract concept the wave function
whatever they want to call it
is at two places at once now they're
saying that an
atom can have you know an atom and now
we're talking about apparently
a real atom maybe a classical atom some
kind of
ball and they say it can have two states
it can be excited or not and
then at the bottom let's say it can also
be at
two positions at the same time again the
they got this from the slit experiment
the
the atom can be at two places at once or
the electron can be in two places at
once
any quantum particle can be in other
words uh
we're done about maybe anything smaller
than an atom
maybe an atom itself if it's small
enough can be a two places at once
and have two excited states in other
words no excitement or
or have excitement and it can be at two
places at once
of course uh no one can understand that
it's irrational to talk like that to say
hey you know
my atom can be in two places at once
well it looks like you're just trying to
cover your um your theory
with some ad hoc notions
that make no sense whatsoever you cannot
even imagine
that you cannot visualize it and again
we're talking about
not that the atoms or the particle in
question
splits we're saying that the at the
particle itself is at two places at once
and why because it's a concept
and even that you cannot i mean what
location does a concept has
have you cannot imagine it under any
circumstance
it's unimaginable that's why mr fireman
said well
we cannot explain it yeah no kidding
okay um and here's uh where they
continue says
you can have this situation in both it
can be not excited
it can be excited okay coming up here
and it can also be both excited and not
excited
and you can see the energy there can
have both
states of energy as they say
what sense does this make how can they
explain it
and you say well you know quantum
mechanics or mathematical physics
they're not interested in explaining um
giving a physical interpretation they
dismiss that as
[Music]
philosophy that's for the philosophers
of physics or philosophers of science or
whatever they want to call
why did they even attempt to explain
or give a physical interpretation to
this
if they realize they don't understand it
they cannot explain it
they com they admit it they confess that
then when you call their bluff and say
but that's irrational they say well yeah
uh that's that's not part of science
that's not part of mathematical physics
that's
or physics uh that's philosophy that's
philosophy of science that's philosophy
of physics
why did they give it why did it even try
well i'll tell you why they had to do it
because otherwise their math
is irrelevant if if their math
has nothing to do with physics they
cannot explain their math
they should not extrapolate it to physic
they should just stick within
their math world and say we measure here
we describe mathematically
we have these equations that's their
world fine
don't step over the line into physics
the reason they step over the line into
physics they want to give you an idea or
they insinuate
and a little more than that really that
they understand and they know
because they're mathematicians and
mathematicians
you know as uh plato used to say in his
door says
no one ignorant geometry should enter
here
like saying hey where where the what
elite cabal
of uh mathematical physics the physics
of science
so they claim to be owners of the
explanations but when you call their
bluff they say well we
can't really understand it but that's
not physics anyways
so why did they try in the first place
because otherwise their math would be
irrelevant
so it's a circular argument okay
keep that in mind that's how that's
what's happening on
in in physics that's why some people
claim that we're at the
end of physics out there and we're
talking about mathematicians saying this
because they cannot explain they reach
the
uh dead well they painted themselves
into a corner
and so they they have no explanations
for these things and so they had to
dismiss that as well that's philosophy
okay so this is where we're at today
okay but what happens
why why does um see if
it can have these two states excited and
not if they're probably going to be at
two places at once
well they cannot explain it but they do
go to the lab and they do get some
conclusions out of it
and what they say is when they look at
it
when they observe it observe whatever
they observe
uh suddenly it collapses to a point to a
specific state
so what they bring at this point is the
seeing
eye the all seeing eye okay now we have
the observer
when the observer is introduced
everything changes
quantum suddenly converts to classical
the unobservable somehow becomes
observable
meaning now they're going to give a
physical interpretation
in classical terms touchable
seeable terms okay
and when you call their bluff because
this touchable seeable again is a
two-state phenomenon that collapses to
one state and you say
well how did that happen by what
mechanism
they say well that's we don't understand
that because that's not science anyways
because we have no way of explaining or
testing what the hypothesis is that what
they call it
testing the hypothesis okay
and so um
oh sorry
so they go on with this
which is the uh measurement problem and
you can see they they're going to
introduce that seeing i
in there okay and when one measures it
only one of the two states is observed
okay that's what they're saying so you
either see it excite excited or not
excited
and you when you observe it it's going
to be at one location or at another not
at two locations at the same time
no kidding i mean if they could observe
the same particle at two places at once
they would be
they would have magical eyes i don't
even think
god can do that even if god is
cross-eyed you know i mean
how can you observe one particle at two
places at once unless you know you drank
too much you know yeah i
i you know i've been over the limit a
couple times and yeah you know
you see the particle at two places at
once but that's my state of mind you
know it has
nothing to do with the real world out
there of the particle being at two
places at once
and again if you can see the uh particle
in two states excited and not excited
well you know i mean and and when you
look at it it
collapses to one or the other
well yeah what is the explanation how
can you explain this
and they say we can't they they they
synthesize it saying
the wave function collapses whoa
that went over my head you must know a
lot because i don't understand that
the wave function collapses what the
hell is that
okay so yeah this is the problem that
they use these fancy terms and people
at that point abandoned the conversation
says well i should study
physics but it's beyond my capability
so i'm not going to deal with that
anymore and i'll let these
uh intelligent mathematicians just go
out and do their work
and because we've developed technology
by trial and error and they say well
it's because we understand
so-called understand uh the in the
invisible world of mother nature is the
the quantum world which they don't
understand
but they say well we do understand it
because we developed a technology
which is classical which has nothing to
do with the quantum explanation which is
no explanation at all
so they use these terms quantum this
quantum dot quantum dot quantum computer
and people say oh yeah it's all
scientific now that's technology has got
nothing to do
with the word quantum okay and this is
where the issue is
they're using these adjectives the
adjective quantum
uh to introduce the
sliding you know the notion that uh the
technology was developed because of
their understanding
of quantum which is absolutely not the
case
as mr feynman will confess to you and
all the mathematicians today will
confess to you
that's why they're saying a lot of them
are saying we're at the end
of physics physics is
has reached or is reaching
brick wall okay um
continuing here uh here's uh one of the
things that they do
they have uh this they call in real life
the quantum objects never completely
isolated because you have all this
environmental
interference or influence okay so they
say the superposition of states
stops after one the oscillations
disappear
and you can see they're building that
curve there okay on the
upper center there they're building that
what a wave that's what they build and
so all they can do
is map it okay they map
uh the wave and uh they're saying
there's some interference they cannot
explain
which they uh simply ascribe to
atoms in the vicinity in the vicinity of
their lab
they can't see those either but they say
well it's got to be there's got to be
atoms there you know arab air
atoms maybe something from the vacuum
because they have that
you know particles coming in from the
vacuum as well and so they use all these
concepts all these
notions and they say there's
interference it's that
interference that screws up their
experiment
among others the fact that you observe
it okay
so one of the issues that you have is
that these people say that just
observing just putting that seeing eye
all seeing eye
into the picture already influences
your experiment at the quantum level
you're hitting it with light
you're throwing a photon at the electron
or the atom or whatever particle you're
analyzing
and so you're already moving it out of
position so you cannot figure out
the position exactly all you can do is
give you a probability of where the
particle might be
and and so they say even the act of
observing
affects your experiment god made it so
that you know observation screws up all
the experiments
at the quantum level and so this these
are the explanations they give you
and then they have no problem they live
with this explanation because they don't
care about the explanation
they they dismiss that as
philosophy but they care about their
equations
and when you ask them well what's the
cause what's the mechanism
they say you're in the wrong form you
know
you got to go through the other side of
campus where the philosophers are at for
that
okay so this is their answer okay um
what's the next thing they have well
they start
they have the starting and the ending
situations okay when you start
you have all these you know can be at
two states at once
and when you end in other words when you
observe it touch it
or interfere with it in some way then it
collapses
to one state or the other or to one
location or the other
meanwhile as long as you don't observe
it you shut your eyes or
don't use your hands then what happens
is the particles at two places at once
it's in two states at once
energy states it's only when you start
looking and touching and
interfering stuff from the environment
and you want to really detect it with
your measurement device or whatever
that's when it collapses and says i
won't let you i won't let you see
or detect or measure or whatever
understand explain what happened in
between
between the world of mother secret world
invisible world of mother nature's
invisible
intangible world unobservable world of
mother natures
and the moment that you did observe
touch c
you know detect measure as soon as you
measure it collapses
and you you lost the information
as they say of what happened just before
you touched it
or saw it or whatever so this is this is
their explanation
and so now for the rest of eternity
that is the explanation they haven't
made any progress in the last hundred
years on this
they keep telling the same thing because
they cannot explain like mr feindon said
at least six uh 45 or 50 years after
quantum mechanics uh took hold that they
still could not explain it and to this
day they cannot explain this
and so if they cannot explain and they
just dismiss explanations
as well as philosophy what the hell
do we need all this math for why are
they developing math
if it has no physical consequences
if they cannot give you a
straightforward explanation
of how this universe works at the
quantum level
so this is this is where we're at that's
why you'll read
some people out there saying well
physics is at a dead end
meaning mathematical physics meaning
mathematics
is at a dead end because they cannot
explain with mathematics all they can do
continue doing is equations
measuring getting out more equations and
the new generation has nothing more to
investigate
in that sense yeah quantum is at a dead
end
and so is general relativity and string
theory they're at a dead end because
the new generation cannot come up with
this magical formula like e equals mc
squared or force equals mass times
acceleration
groundbreaking um equations
in mathematical physics they gave them
an insight of
how forces or gravity
work meaning descriptions mathematical
descriptions
they cannot do that anymore because they
develop math to
their ridiculous levels unnecessary
levels and they still cannot give you a
straightforward explanation for how
gravity works how quantum works how
general relativity works how
strengthener you were they have no
explanations no mechanisms no
causes okay why because math
cannot give you any explanation
math is strictly strictly only
a discipline or language
really it's a language that can only
describe
it has no power whatsoever to explain
and
people don't understand that out there
if they understood that mathematics
would die tomorrow morning
you know like hitting a brick wall why
because
people say oh you mean you can only
describe
but i don't care about your mathematical
equations i don't care about your
descriptions
i want an explanation i want to know
what gravity is how how mother nature
does that trick that i let go of the pen
you know
and it falls to the floor not to the
ceiling how come it doesn't
go to the ceiling well they cannot
explain that to you why because for that
you need
objects in order explaining mechanism
you need
objects otherwise you're introducing
spirits
by default okay okay
so uh let's go to the conclusions
okay here are my conclusions on the
uh this uh the coherence i call it
incoherence okay
quantum decoherence has to do with
unobservable mediators that
intervene during phenomena such as the
double slit experiment in atomic
excitation
okay simulating these phenomena with
discrete particles has led
mathematicians to ridiculous conclusions
okay and uh here are three examples
particle is at two places at once or can
be a two or is
it's not that it can be it is they say
in fact it's uh more than one place it
can be at several places at once
an atom is both excited and not has
these two
energy states and measurement collapses
the wave function
whatever that meant to you how do you
collapse a wave function
i mean you're using terms of physics and
you're applying it to concepts
you know flat space time what do you
mean by flat space time
how can space time which is a constant
be flat and this is more or less the
same thing how can you collapse a wave
function is a
wave function is you know is a uh
an equation it's a concept we don't
collapse concepts
meaning physically you know i can
collapse a balloon but not a collapse
a wave function and so it's the language
that has
permeated the public those people who
are interested in all these subjects
that people just take for granted i know
you should put them against the wall and
ask them to define these terms
yeah you got to really put them against
the wall and say look make sense
you don't make sense you're not part of
science that's what people have to do
so yeah i propose that quantum the
coherence be called quantum
incoherence all these guys that
graduate and have phds in mathematical
physics
well maybe they're just uh incoherent
people
that's all they are why are we treating
them as gods
because they can do all those equations
okay
uh you know you you glorify them you
turn them into god because they know how
to do an equation and then they give you
a ridiculous explanation
so now i suggest that instead of the
coherence
we call them incoherence or
incoherent people okay and that would
really uh
set the stage for the public to
understand that these folks
don't
okay let's go with the questions today
here we have
one fellow says definition of
irrational says reptoid
meaning me making up his own definition
scientific method and making fun of
mathematics calling it rational science
reptoid where did he get that i mean you
know i mean
am i a reptoid
uh i don't know where he got that idea
how come i he calls me a reptoid
okay but no we do have a definition
of irrational okay and uh so you know
here it is
okay and here are the
criteria i guess you could say okay and
uh i'll just go through them the first
one is treating concepts as
objects in other words known as
reification
these are the criteria again for
irrationality using inconsistent
definitions or none at all
theory no undefined words in other words
that's what i mean by none at all
no definitions theory is inconsistent or
doesn't follow from the assumptions
describing especially mathematically and
having claimed to
uh explained and
that the mechanism or the assumption
doesn't work or cannot even be
imagined okay so we do have a definition
for what a rational
is what this is saying is that i'm
making up my own definitions that's not
there is no such thing as own
definitions all we have is scientific
definitions and
definitions which are not scientific and
the way you do that you get in
the ring you don't introduce democracy
you don't introduce voting you don't
introduce tradition you don't say well
this is how we always been using it
no no if it's wrong you got to correct
it just because you've used it for a
million years doesn't mean you got to
continue
using it if it's irrational and making
fun of mathematics yeah because these
people claim to
explain then they dismiss it as
philosophy and then they again say well
we can explain because we call it
quantum computers or
quantum dots or whatever they're going
to call the technology
so you know yeah we do have to make fun
of them
especially because they are uh
irrational okay
and yeah all this fellow has to do is
define the word rational
very simple you define the word rational
or irrational whichever one
and defend it because not a question of
saying well that's my opinion
we don't care your opinion what we care
is for you to present your case
get in the ring defend it against all
attackers
okay i think i can defend each one of my
definitions i worked
on my definitions quite a bit so when i
put them out there
usually uh i've made errors
i believe i had to modify a couple my
of my definitions but i think most of
them were pretty much on the money okay
money is something that's going to
disappear we're going to
not believe in money soon okay and
here's another issue say by what
mechanism can you explain how the
water is held on the earth while
spinning and traveling through space at
1.5 million
miles per hour if you say gravity please
explain with
one and what mechanism
i've explained this in the past uh
someone pointed it out to there but let
me just go through it
quickly once again here it is uh here's
an astronaut we'll go
in steps here okay here's an astronaut
flying to earth
okay why does he fall to earth why does
he just
continue floating and go to jupiter
i mean you know he's got a free ride he
doesn't have to worry about
taking a rocket out there you know in
space
if he's just going to fall to earth
something is drawing him there otherwise
he would continue floating all the way
to jupiter and out the solar system
why doesn't he what's bringing him down
to earth
i mean he's he's far away in space maybe
not far away enough maybe he's in
between the earth and the moon somewhere
you know we have almost uh one light
second distance
between earth and the moon let's round
it off to 300 000 kilometers
distance uh between the two
he's 150 kilo 150 000
kilometers away from earth okay he's in
the middle there
why doesn't he drift out into nowhere
he's far away from earth no he's gonna
gradually be
falling to earth until he falls faster
and faster and faster and faster as you
can see there
the astronaut does fall faster as he
gets closer to the earth it's known as
gravitational acceleration
here on earth it's 9.8 meters per second
squared okay that's the value
okay and uh so here's a static version
of that so that you can see
what is happening okay the astronaut
really
as he's far away you can see the ropes
because he's attached
every atom in his body is attached to
every atom on earth
now we have a physical mechanism for why
this astronaut is falling
okay that's the important part here the
important part there is something that
is
invisible intangible and we say that all
atoms are interconnected by
this invisible intangible medium
object thing and it looks like a rope
more or less like
dna okay and if every atom of his body
is tied to every atom on earth
when he's far away all these ropes more
or less converge
upon a single coaxial you can say it's
almost a straight line the farther away
he is
but as he approaches the earth these
ropes are not on the same axis
anymore they don't superimpose they
branch out
they fan out okay and so the closer he
gets the more the
ropes fan out and the more we say that
he weighs
what is weight weight is a function of
the number of ropes
effective ropes as we call them the
number of ropes is always the same it's
just that
the effective ropes the ones that are
not on the same axis
are the ones that are essentially
causing his weight to increase
okay so there are more and more ropes uh
essentially that are not on the same
axis
and he weighs more the closer he is
closer to earth
that's just a simple how simple it is
okay
okay so um here we have uh
a situation so we're working on the
answering this gentleman's question okay
and here it is you have one atom and let
me remove this one
we have one atom and we'll call that the
earth you can call it any object you
want you got a ball
doesn't matter but we'll call it the
earth and the closer
the well the the atom this atom is tied
to every atom
on earth so it's
on the well what uh upper right hand
corner
you can call it northwest uh northeast
okay
so it's being pulled by or or the ropes
are expanding in the direction of where
all the atoms on earth are
so they fan out in that direction here
we have another atom i'll put it next to
it so you can see what's happening here
okay and this is on the other side well
which direction do you think that atom
is going to fall towards
what's going to fall towards the center
of the earth so both these atoms are on
opposite sides because
each one of these atoms is is attached
to
every atom on earth they're pulled
towards the center of the earth
okay in other words they drift in that
direction that atom is drifting towards
that
direction because that's where all
most of the uh influence is coming from
okay so this is this is what you got to
keep in mind this is how we're going to
explain this gravity thingy
okay and here we see a dynamic version
of that okay
and it applies not only to uh the
water as he asked it applies to air as
well i mean
air what is air a gas and
why doesn't that air drift away that's
you know enveloping our earth
it's encapsulating on earth okay
why does it why does each one of those
atoms just drift away what's keeping it
bound to the earth
you know and that's the issue with the
flat earthers okay
they always ask how can you curve water
well here it is how you can curve water
and why there is no other possibility
and again you don't look at the water in
your bathroom and say well that's not
curved it's flat
no no you got to look at the water
around the earth you got to look at a
major object
okay in fact the water on your bathtub
is also curved but
you know you're not going to be able to
measure it it's
essentially going to be a straight line
and for as much as you measure all those
drops of water are going to be
essentially straight and you know a flat
surface you're going to get
from that water if nothing else moves
now you got to do with a major object
like the earth and then you can figure
out why water curves
water occurs because every atom of water
is tied to every atom on earth and the
same thing happens with
air air curves around the earth
encapsulates the global
the ball we call earth because every
atom is pulled towards the center of the
earth drifts in that direction because
all the ropes
are fanning out in that direction
there are other ropes tied to the moon
to jupiter to pluto to the sun
but those objects are very far away and
you have that situation where
they all converge on pretty much a
single coaxial
it's almost a straight line but here
where it's the distance is what makes
the difference that's why
newton's formula equation is a function
of distance
square of the distance in fact the
inverse function but why because
that atom you know the closer it gets to
earth the more the ropes fan out the
farther away it gets
the weaker gravity is because they all
approach a single coaxial it's like you
have a single
rope pulling on that object very far
away at infinity
you could say okay so this is the
mechanism
of gravity okay okay another question
another common person made
says you can pull a particle by throwing
another particle at it if
particles can pulsate in size
my god uh no
you can't do anything i mean people have
this notion some of them have what
pressure
you know they have this casimir effect
you remove whatever's in between two
objects and the
particles from the outside push the two
objects together
and yeah i mean here's the other
possibility
and that's known as the gluon uh i call
it the glue and attractions the
negative momentum transfer okay and what
you say is you throw a
quark throws a glue on it another quark
and draws it towards it
that's how they work within the proton
or within the neutron
can you explain that can you explain how
you throw a glue on and you attract
that's what we need to explain and what
you're doing is
using black magic to produce this effect
there's no way you can
explain this any in classical terms not
if these two quarks
are independent they're not tied to each
other in any way
okay and you have also entanglement
where if one turns uh clockwise the
other one
turns counterclockwise and vice versa
how can you explain that with action at
a distance you got to put
spirits in between the two objects
that's the only way and this is more or
less the same thing if you're going to
throw a ball
in this case a glue on it at quark and
you're going to attract it
please explain the mechanism in
classical terms
in other words tell us in a rational
manner
how how that gluon pulls on that quark
and no you can't it's
irrational okay
and let me put myself back in here and
here we have the last uh common last
question
phil says uh he tells me go see
this uh video and uh
he says what they explain there or try
to
they don't explain but he says they
claim that we can
uh bend the concept called space yeah
concept uh using the concept called
mass yeah in order to travel really fast
and you're talking about the aqua beer
uh warp drive
okay essentially that's what there's the
link you can
go there and if you go to this uh
place it'll talk about the alcubierre
wart drive and what it is is essentially
a bubble
within space-time and they do this fancy
math
again no explanation it's just math
where they say well mathematically we
can travel faster in light
what is the issue the issue is that all
these people
want to be able to travel to the nearest
star and they can't do so
using classical uh systems
in other words how do you travel forget
about faster in light even at the speed
of light
einstein said you can't do that because
you convert yourself into energy
you're no longer mass now you've turned
yourself into energy
and so there's no way you arrive as mass
unless
you somehow you know do one of these
transportations that they did in star
trek where you know
they re reconstruct you on the other
side magically again
all magic and so this so how do you do
this alcubia
drive well you can't you can't because
it's a bubble within space time that
somehow
moves much faster in light okay
and they also use wormholes for this
they also use
dark matter and what is it uh
black holes you know you go through the
wormhole and
appear on the other side because they
they want
they want to give hope to people that
were not stuck on the planet
that somehow we're going to be able to
conquer those enormous
distances to the nearest star near a
star 4.3 light years away
that's a measure of distance centauri
three-star
system triple star system and it's 4.3
light years away traveling at the speed
of light you arrive one way
in four years round trip
rounding off nine years is that possible
no it's impossible you'll never get to
the nearest star we'll never colonize
the nearest star there's no
physical way of doing that you can only
do it mathematically and mathematics you
can do whatever you want you can change
mass
energy distance time you can do whatever
you want and that's why
they play around with these notions they
say oh look what if
i mean these people are not even no
longer have their feet on the ground
anymore
okay and so they're working on stuff
that has no bearing whatsoever on our
reality out there
they don't have their feet on the ground
and so they want to overcome
distances time etc and the way they do
it is mathematically
and then they sell it to the public as
physics they say oh you know
the laws of physics allow it now they're
talking about
the equations of mathematical physics
allow it but it has nothing to do with
reality in great measure because a lot
of these equations have what is known as
infinities in them and that's when they
say well the laws of physics
break down at infinity meaning at the
singularity or whatever they want to
call it
and so they don't have a physical
interpretation they play around with
these things
they make movies because they say well
we're not really making
a uh a movie on um
fiction you know science fiction no this
is science because the mathematicians
told us that this is possible
and so you have all this star trek stuff
out there
and they travel from one star system to
another at the
faster the speed of thought you think
and you're already there
and they sell to the public as science
as it's not
science fiction it's a documentary
and people believe it people say well if
the scientists the mathematicians they
say it's real then it must be real you
know i mean
who knows better on earth than all these
mathematicians
all these new platonic people
the plato's of today you know
no one ignorant of geometry may may
enter here okay so yeah
they sell they have to sell you this
warp drive stuff
to give you hope that there is a chance
to reach the nearest star and for that
they need the mathematicians politicians
are also happy with it because they say
oh
all these mathematicians are telling the
ignorant public out there
that we can do all these things god let
them talk
let them talk it's good it's good for
morale it gives people hope
there is no hope we can't reach the
nearest star we will not
conquer the galaxy and have
all these types of civilizations that
they've developed
out there you know level one two and
three none of that will ever happen
we're about to die folks we're we're the
last humans on earth
someone's gonna be turning off the light
pretty soon and so to think to
even have hope sorry i don't like to
give hope
people hate me for that but uh i've got
my feet on the ground
i say it like it is there is no hope
we'll never reach the nearest eye i
don't even think we'll even make it to
mars
that might happen still maybe
if elon musk has his way but we have no
chance whatsoever
colonizing mars what are we going to
mars for just to
make someone rich because he's got a
travel agency to a space travel agency
is that what it's all about we're not
going to
live on mars we're not going to
terraform mars we're not going to put a
station on mars where
humans live there for a period of time
we're certainly not going to colonize if
anything
we send a probe out there maybe with
humans
they stay a little while then come back
and say hell we made it to mars that's
about as far as we'll ever get
why are we doing that i have no idea
it's just to give people
hope that's all it is that we can
uh conquer space and
that's about as as far as we can get
there is no hope folks and i'm sorry to
be so
i'm not negative i'm realistic
i'm not uh pessimistic i'm realistic
with that i'll see you on sunday we'll
see you then bye bye